The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Settle down.
Settle down.
All right, first announcement
is the
celebration of learning.
Reminding you that the
celebration of learning is a
week from today.
Go to your assigned rooms. A
through Ha will write in here.
This group will go
into 26-100.
And the last group
over to 4-270.
And you will take with you your
periodic table, table of
constants, aid sheet, something
to write with.
And we'll give you paper.
You'll write on the
exam paper itself.
And I'll say more about test
taking strategies on Monday.
Coverage will be right
up through Monday.
With emphasis obviously on the
material that you've had some
time to digest. And there will
be no weekly quiz next week.
So let's get right
into the lesson.
Last day we looked at Louis,
who gave us the notion of
achieving octet stability
by electron sharing.
And that led to the concept
of covalent bonds.
And then Pauling helped us
understand the energetics of
covalent bonding by putting
forth the idea in a
heteronuclear molecule
there's unequal
sharing of the electrons.
And out of that emerged the
concept of polar covalency and
the definition of
electronegativity.
And on the slide you see how
electronegativity varies
across the periodic table.
Electronegativity being a
measure of the pull an atom
has for electrons within
a covalent bond.
And as you would expect, the
non metals which are good
electronic receptors are also
the ones that have the highest
electronegativity.
And the metals, over here, which
are good electron donors
are those that have the
the lowest value of
electronegativity.
And Pauling was quantitative in
his formulation and gave us
this equation that tells us how
to measure the energy of
the x-y covalent bond.
If x is not equal to y, then
axiomatically this is going to
be a polar covalent bond.
And you take the geometric
mean of the
homonuclear bond energies.
This is x-x bond energy
in x two.
This is the y-y bond
energy in y two.
You take the product square
root of which.
And then the partial ionic
character, this is the
contribution to unequal sharing
of the electrons.
You take the square of
the difference in the
electonegativities of
the two elements.
And the 96.3 is a factor that
allows you to get the overall
quantity in kilojoules
per mole.
So you need these numbers
in kilojoules per mole.
And we further had a formula
for the percent ionic
character, which you can get by
looking at the difference
in electronegativity.
And then through this formula,
you end up with a scale that
runs from 0 to 100%.
And just by way of example,
we had a look at H-F.
We spent a fair bit
of time on that.
Obviously, it's a heteronuclear
molecule.
We calculated its bond
energy and so on.
And then to indicate
polar covalency, we
use the dipole notation.
The dipole shown here.
It's just an oval.
It's net neutral.
But the charge is not uniformly
distributed.
You see one end is a little
more negative.
The other end is a little
more positive.
Sometimes people write lowercase
Greek delta,
indicating little bit negative
here, a little bit positive
here, net neutral.
There's the arrow indicating
the dipole.
And furthermore, we argue that
this is a polar bond.
And since this is just a
molecule with the two atoms,
then this is also a
polar molecule.
Which means it has a
net dipole moment.
And I made some observations
about dipole moments and the
ability to store energy
capacitively.
And how you'd go about finding
a really good capacitor.
And so that all came out of the
desire to find something
that has a net dipole moment.
And I want to continue
that conversation.
And so I want to look at
some other elements.
And what I want to look
at in particular is
the compound methane.
Let's look at methane from this
new found appreciation of
polar covalency.
So first thing I want to do is
to put it's structure up.
We've gone through the Louis
notation and the structure.
It forms sp3 hybrids.
And you end up with a structure
that looks like this.
These are all at a 109 degrees,
symmetrically
disposed in space.
And we know since we have a
heteronuclear system here,
we're going to have some
polar covalency.
You can look up that the
electronegativity of carbon is
2.55 electronegativity of
hydrogen is less than that
from its position in
the periodic table.
But to be quantitative
it's 2.2.
So that means if I look at the
carbon hydrogen bond, carbon
has the higher
electronegativity.
So it's going to pull
the electrons.
So that means that the carbon
end is going to be a little
bit negative.
And the hydrogen end is going
to be a little bit positive.
So that means I've got
a dipole moment here.
Polar bond.
Everything is the same
as above here.
Polar bond.
But, I want to address
the question, is
the molecule polar?
So the way I interpret the
question, is it a polar
molecule, I ask is there a
net charge displacement?
Well, we're off to a
good start here.
We see that we have charge
displacement on the bonds.
But, is there a net dipole
for the molecule.
So the way I think about that is
to say, where is the center
of positive charge
for the molecule?
Where's the center of
negative charge?
So I know all the hydrogens
are a little bit positive.
And they're all the same
distance from the nucleus.
And I can draw a circle
that will
capture all four hydrogens.
Or more appropriately,
it's a sphere, right?
These three on the bottom
don't lie in the plane.
So the corners of the
tetrahedron lie on a sphere.
So where is the center
of positive charge?
The center positive charge is
right here at the center of
the molecule.
And where's the center of
local negative charge?
It's on the carbon because the
carbon is the negative end of
all the bonds.
So the centers of positive and
negative charge for the entire
molecule are colocated at the
center of the molecule.
So this means no net
dipole moments.
No net dipole moment
for the molecule.
So this is a non
polar molecule.
It's a non polar molecule
consisting of polar bonds.
Non polar molecule.
So there's two ways that I can
get a non polar molecule.
One way is to have a homonuclear
molecule, right?
So, homonuclear molecule.
Homonuclear molecules
axiomatically must be non polar.
Because they have
equal sharing.
So if I give you anything that's
homonuclear trivially,
it's non polar.
So you can look at things
like H2, P4, S8.
These things are
all non polar.
I don't care what
their structures
are, it doesn't matter.
This one here is definitely
polar.
And then the last one here that
we're looking at, the the
methane, is non polar because
we have spatially symmetric
disposition of identical
polar bonds.
So spatially symmetric, that
means there's three
dimensional symmetry.
Spatially symmetric disposition
of identical polar
bonds leads to non
polar molecule.
Because the centers of positive
and negative charge
are colocated.
So, now it's time to move on.
Now I want to look at covalent
bonding from an energetic
standpoint.
I want to go back to energy
level diagrams. We've looked
at energy level diagrams in
the past for atoms, single
atoms. But now, what I want to
do is build energy level
diagrams for molecules.
So, for that we're going
to go back to
the Schrodinger equation.
I want energy level diagrams
for molecules.
And for that I'm going to call
upon the Schrodinger equation.
And we're not going to go
through the quantum mechanics
in mathematical detail.
We're going to do quantum
mechanics pictorally.
We've got a long way.
And in particular, what I want
to do with regard to the
Schrodinger equation is to
recognize that we can move
from atomic orbitals to
molecular orbitals by
exploiting the fact that the
Schrodinger equation is a
linear equation.
Using the linearity property
of Schrodinger equation.
All right, what do I
mean by linearity?
Well, I'm going to do just
a little bit of math.
Just enough to make you sit up
in your math classes and find
out that there's some
utility there.
Here's what I mean.
Let me talk about what the
linearity principal is.
So if I have some equation,
f of x, y, and z.
It's a three variable
equation.
And the equation is f
of x, y, z is k1.
k1 could be a constant, it could
be a function, it could
be anything.
And let's say that it
has as its solution,
the solution is s1.
And then I've got a second
variant of this x, y, z.
And it equals k2.
So it's the same function
but it equals k2 here.
It could be a constant, it
could be something else.
And it has as its
solution, s2.
If this f of x, y, z is a linear
equation, then if I'd
give you f of x, y, z equals k1
plus k2, you don't have to
go and solve the equation
with impunity.
You can write that
the solution is
equal to s1 plus s2.
And that doesn't hold if it's
a non linear equation.
Just put y equals x squared.
And if I tell you y equals one,
y equals two, and then I
give you y equals 1 plus 2, it
doesn't equal the sum of the
solution to that.
You can prove it to yourself.
So this is the fact that
superposition holds.
You can superpose solutions
and build a library.
So superposition holds when you
have a linear equation.
And that's all we're going to
use in order to make equations
for the molecular orbital.
So that way I can write that
the wave function of a
molecular orbital then is a
linear combination of the
atomic orbitals.
That's all this is doing.
This is setting the stage for,
if you take quantum mechanics
later, you'll go through
this in gory detail.
But I'm saying that you know
enough now to appreciate that
we can do what we're
about to do so.
That means I'm just going to sum
the wave functions of the
atomic orbitals.
In this case, i goes from 1 to
2 because there's only two
orbitals in a bond.
And there will be some pre
factor here, a sub i times ci.
And this whole business is
called linear combination of
atomic orbitals into
molecular orbitals.
So it's an SLI, it's a six
letter initialization.
You know like FBI is a TLI,
it's a three letter
initialization.
This is an SLI, in
3L91 we go big.
This is an SLI, six letter
initialization.
So we're going to do
some examples here.
And all you need to do in order
to run the examples is
use two ideas in LCAO-MO.
First of all, conservation
of states.
Conservation of orbital
states.
And the second one is, we're
going to fill the newly
created molecular orbitals
according
to the Aufbau principle.
Fill MOs by Aufbau.
If we do that, we're
in good shape.
So let's take a look.
So first think I want
to do is just
rationalize this one here.
H plus H goes to H2.
I want to demonstrate
that there's a
rational basis for this.
So what I'm going to do is make
energy level diagrams. So
there's an energy
coordinate here.
Energy goes up in the
vertical direction.
And out here is zero.
And what I'm going to draw for
you is energy level diagrams
for two atomic hydrogen
gas atoms.
So if this is the zero,
we know that somewhere
down here is the 1s.
And I'm going to be complete
in my label.
This is the 1s atomic
orbital of hydrogen.
And over here there's
a 1s atomic
orbital of atomic hydrogen.
And furthermore, I've got an
electron sitting in 1s.
Now these are at infinite
separation.
These are far apart.
Far, you know what that means.
Far with quotation marks means
that they're separate quantum
systems. So I'm not violating
the poly exclusion principal
by having both of these
electrons sitting in the
ground state.
So they both have the same
set of quantum numbers.
1, 0, 0, 1/2.
Both of them.
Same thing.
Let's put it over here,
1, 0, 0, 1/2.
So they're very,
very far apart.
Now if I bring them close enough
together to make the
molecule H2, what happens is I'm
going to violate the poly
exclusion principal if I have
both of these atomic orbitals
at the same level.
Because I start filling them
according to Aufbau principal
I'm going to end up with
more electrons than
two at the same state.
So what happens is
this splits.
One orbitals ends up at a lower
energy and one orbital
ends up at a higher energy than
the ground state energy
in the atom itself.
And so now this is called the
sigma 1s molecular orbital.
And the one above it is
called sigma star
1s molecular orbital.
And sigma is at a
lower energy.
So if electrons populate this
orbital, the system's energy
will decrease and a
bond will form.
So this is called a
bonding orbital.
If electrons populate the upper
orbital, they will raise
the energy of the system,
destabilizing it.
And so this orbital denoted
with the star is called
antibonding.
It's an antibonding orbital.
So now I've got the energy
level diagram
for molecular hydrogen.
So now let's go and
populate according
to the Aufbau principal.
I've got two electrons and they
go in spin up spin down.
And now you can see that this
occupancy put the electrons at
lower energy than they were by
being in the energy state of
the atoms.
And so I can argue that by
this diagram, I haven't
predicted anything, but I
can use this diagram to
rationalize that for this
reaction delta E is negative.
And we know how negative
it is.
It's minus 435 kilojoules
per mole.
It's hugely negative.
Minus 435 kilojoules per mole.
All right.
So, that's good.
In fact I think I've
got some pictures.
You can go through the whole
quantum mechanics.
And just as is the case for a
single atoms, you can use the
product of the wave function and
it's complex conjugate and
so on and make plots.
Oh by the way, this was just
making the point that you can
pull out the electronegativity
off of the periodic table.
It's given here.
And the periodic table
is pretty good.
But obviously somebody got a
little bit ahead of himself.
They called this the first
ionization potential, which is
the potential you'd put
across the plates in a
gas discharge tube.
But the unit is not
the electronvolt.
If it's a potential,
it's a volt.
Somebody here that put this
together seemed to think the
electronvolt is a unit
of potential.
And I want to make sure
that nobody in this
class believes that.
You got to get a little bit of
nail polish or something and
cover up the little e there.
Or take the nail polish, paint
over potential and write first
ionization energy.
One or the other,
but not this.
This was a plot if percent
ionic characters.
You can see that the strongly
covalent compounds down here
have very very low
electronegativity differences
and therefore very low
ionic character.
And way up here are
the ionics.
And in between is HF.
It's almost at the cusp.
But, can you see that
there must be a
mistake on this diagram?
Because this thing has got a
greater electronegativity
difference than lithium iodide
and yet lithium iodide has a
higher percent ionic
character.
How can this function
zigzag like that?
Something's wrong.
So when you look at something,
you go wait a minute, that
doesn't make sense.
So I go back and I say, do
I trust anything here?
Trust, but verify.
Read critically.
It's a good book.
But, it's a big book
and there's
going to be some mistakes.
All right, so here's some
pictoral stuff of what we were
just doing over here.
So here are the two spherical 1s
orbitals and now they come
closer and closer together
and they overlap.
And this is what the shape
of the sigma 1s
orbital looks like.
It's like an oval with the
two nuclei inside.
Here's taken from a different
text book.
The overlap of atomic 1s atomic
and now here's the
molecular orbital.
Now you can also look at what
the shape of the antibonding
orbital would be.
This is what the shape of the
antibonding orbital would be.
It would have two lobes with
a nodal plane in between.
I think this is taken from
yet another book.
Oh this is our book.
There we go.
1s, 1s, as there we go.
Hydrogen molecular orbitals.
Now look, suppose we do the
same thing for helium.
If we do the same thing for
helium, helium starts with two
electrons in 1s.
And now it's going to
have four electrons.
Two will go in the bonding
and two will go in the
antibonding.
And the two that go in the
antibonding raise the energy
of the system more than the
two that go into bonding
decrease the energy
of the system.
There's a net increase
in energy.
And this is the way you could
rationalize that helium exists
as the atom in the gas phase.
You don't see He2
gas molecules.
So using this energy level
diagram you can go through an
rationalize.
I would never ask
you to predict.
I would say, fact, helium is
found as the atomic species in
the gas phase.
With the use of energy level
diagrams, rationalize.
And that's what I would
expect you to do.
Take this and show
that the two are
of different stability.
One other point to to make,
the level of 1s.
If I wanted to put helium
on this board here.
Not the scale, but
just roughly.
Where would helium 1s be
relative the hydrogen 1s.
We got three choices.
Same level, closer to zero
energy, or more negative.
How do you think about
the problem?
What determines what
this energy is?
It's the electrostatic
force of attraction.
Is the electrostatic force of
attraction on the 1s electron
in helium greater than or less
than it is in hydrogen?
It's greater.
So that means that the energy is
going to be more negative.
And so if I were to put over
here helium, I'd put down here
this would be 1s atomic orbital
for helium and then we
go through the analysis.
And why does that
come into play?
Well you might want to do a
heteronuclear molecule.
Suppose you wanted to do
the bonding diagram
for hydrogen fluoride.
So we'd have hydrogen here
and the fluorine
and would be here.
And all the fluorine orbitals
would be much lower and then
they'd combine to make the
molecular orbitals.
And I think there's something
opportunities to practice that
in the homework.
OK let's do one more.
Let's do one more.
How about lithium.
Let's do lithium.
I want to ask, is dilithium
stable?
Li2.
And this is all gas phase.
Is dilithium stable?
So I'll start off with
here's the zeroes.
The zero of energy for
infinite separation.
So this'll be a lithium
gas atom.
And this is the putative
dilithium gas atom.
We're going to figure out
if it's stable or not.
So it's going to have bonding
and antibonding orbitals.
And then this is the 1s, 2s.
And this will be sigma 1s,
sigma star 1s, and so on.
And then we'll have 2s atomic
orbital splitting into sigma
and sigma star of 2s.
And now lithium is 1s2, 2s1.
So there's one, two, three.
And one, two, three.
And so now let's use
the Hund rule.
So I've got four electrons in
the n equals one shell, and
they populate in this manner.
And then I've got two electrons
that go only into
the bonding orbital.
And according to this it appears
that lithium 2 is
favored over atomic lithium.
And that in fact is the case.
That in fact is the case and so
that applies to all of the
all of the alkalide metals.
Because they all have the
ns1 configuration.
So when you're driving down the
highway and you see those
orangey yellow low pressure
sodium vapor lamps.
What you're looking at is
emission not from atomic
sodium but from Na2 vapor.
And you've got the energy level
diagram to convince
yourself of that.
So next time you see those,
just smile, knowing that
you're looking at disodium,
not sodium.
OK, well so far we've only
looked at single bonds.
Now I want to look at
multiple bonds.
Double and triple bonds.
So let's look at nitrogen now.
N2.
Remember that gave us
the the triple bond?
We had nitrogen, one, two,
three, four, five.
Second nitrogen, one, two,
So in order to get octet
stability, we had three pairs
of electronic sharing.
Which then give us a
triple bond here.
And so what's that going
to look like?
what's that going to look
like pictorally?
And the way to think about that
is first of all these are
all p orbitals.
If we look at, this
is 2s2, 2p3.
So 2s and these are
the 2d orbitals.
So I've got s is filled first
and then I've got the lone
electrons in each of
the p orbitals.
And these things are shaped
like figure eights.
And the p orbital, this is
the p atomic orbital.
It has two lobes.
Each of these zones are
just called lobes.
Same word is earlobe.
And this zone in the middle,
this one point in the middle,
is called a node.
And that's a sight of zero
electron density.
Zero electronic density.
And remember the electron,
even if it only has one
electron here, the electron
can be in either a lobe.
It can move from lobe to lobe
even though it can never be at
the nucleus.
And how does it get from one
lobe to the other while never
crossing the nucleus because
it's never supposed to be in
the nucleus?
By behaving as a wave. The same
way that you can have a
jump rope and you can have a
fixed point of zero motion,
yet you can transmit energy down
the rope passed the node.
So, let's draw these things.
A word about how you draw,
you have to use
the right hand rule.
Have to use the right
hand rule.
So when I put the coordinate
system up, it's going to have
to conform so that the thumb
is x and they go y and z.
And if you don't use the right
hand rule later on if you get
into electromagnetics, you start
looking at forces and
vectors, you're going to end up
with things moving in the
wrong direction.
So we conform to the
right hand rule.
And the other thing,
and it's kind of
nice, it's not mandatory.
But chemists generally
like to have atoms
bond along the z-axis.
So that means we start with the
z-axis here, if I'm going
to put my second nitrogen, have
them bond on the z-axis.
And so that means if z is in
the plane of the board
pointing to the right, then
pointing up must be y, and
then pointing into the
board must be x.
So I'll have, here's my px
orbital, then the py orbital,
and the pz orbital.
And the three of these are all
symmetrically disposed around
the nucleus.
And next to it at the same kind
of floral arrangement.
I'll start with px,
py, and pz.
And now these are going
to come close
together and overlap.
So I want to figure out what
those orbitals are
going to look like.
So let's start along
the z-axis.
The z-axis is the easy one.
So I've got two of these things
lying on their sides
like infinity signs.
We're going to do quantum
mechanics pictorally.
Why?
Because it's a linear
equation.
So I can add pictural.
So this is 2pz of one of them.
And a 2pz of the other.
And this is the nitrogen
atomic orbital.
And I'm going to smear these
things and what are they going
to look like?
The nucleus is here, the
nucleus is where I'm
indicating the dot.
These two combine, very
simply, it's going
to look like this.
So there's one nitrogen.
Here's the other nitrogen.
And what's this thing?
This is electronic density.
And so this is our sigma bond.
Looks a little bit different
from the case of of hydrogen,
because hydrogen was the
blending of two s orbitals and
s orbitals are spherically
symmetric.
In this case, we've
got two lobes.
But what's characteristic about
this one and hydrogen,
hydrogen looked like
this, remember?
This was hydrogen.
This was H2.
And this was a sigma bond.
The characteristic of a sigma
bond is that when you start
from one nucleus and you go to
the other nucleus, you move
through unbroken electron
density.
So there are no nodes, no
holidays, between the nitrogen
nucleus on the left and the
nitrogen nucleus on the right.
There is a node here, but
that's different.
I can go from one nitrogen to
the other with unbroken
electron density.
That's what makes this
a sigma bond.
So that's good.
So this thing here is going
to be called stigma
2p molecular orbital.
Sigma 2p molecular orbital And
I think I've got the slide
that shows this.
There's some art work.
People really get excited
about this.
OK there's dilithium.
Or dipotasium, disodium.
OK so here we are.
This is the smearing of two pz
atomic orbitals to make the
sigma 2p bonding orbital.
And there just for grins and
chuckles is what the
antibonding would look like.
But we don't care, because
it doesn't form.
Well this is the book.
And you know what I'm
going to say.
I've got my little
hobby horse here.
I don't know why they change
color on the lobes.
Because when I look at that, it
starts conjuring up to me
the image that one electron
stays in the blue lobe and one
electron stays in
the yellow lobe.
Besides, I've seen them and
they're not different colors.
They're the same color.
So now let's look at what
happens when we blend off of
the z-axis.
So let's blend the
two py orbitals.
See what that goes like.
OK so let's do that one.
And that one is going
to look like this.
We're to start with, again
figure eights.
But now they're their side
by side, they're lateral.
So this is 2py atomic orbital.
2py atomic orbital.
And then we're going to blend
them along the z-axis to give
us, and I'm going to do
this stylized, OK?
So there's the the two
nitrogen nuclei.
So I put the nuclei up.
And I'm going to smear
the upper lobes.
So these two lobes are
going to smear.
And I'm going to get
really stylized.
I feel like it's France and
it's the late 1800s.
So there it is.
And I'm going to smear
the two bottom ones.
And it's going to
look like this.
So what do I have here?
Now I have two lobes
as before.
But if I look at the second
nucleus from the first
nucleus, not only do I fail
to have unbroken electron
density, I have zero
electron density.
See, this was a nodal
point in the atom.
With the two atoms together,
the plane orthogonal to the
board is a nodal plane.
There's no electron density
in the plane
orthogonal to the board.
Nodal plane.
So this is definitely not a
sigma bond, this is a pi bond.
This is a pi bond.
And it's characterized by
smearing of atomic orbitals,
just as the sigma bond is.
But it has a nodal plane that
separates the two lobes.
I think I've got some cartoon
illustrations from other books
Here OK this is from one book.
This is good.
They call the px,
I call it py.
There it is.
And I'd go further and I'd say
that if I were to slice this
and look at it from angle, if
we were to cut this and look
from here, I'd venture that
you'd see something that's
sort of figure eightish.
Oh here's our book, bless
them with two colors.
But anyway, there's what
it looks like.
That's the pie.
And then the same thing
happens with the x.
So this is this is going
to be pi 2py.
This is pi 2py.
And it's a molecular orbital.
And there's going
to be a pi 2px.
And it's going to blend
front and back.
So we can make a catalog.
So we're going to do quantum
mechanics in pictures here.
So I know that s plus s must
always make a sigma bond.
There's no other way.
Because I've got electron
density all around.
Let's do it pictorally.
That's easy.
And this is sigma.
We know this has to be sigma.
What about something like HF
where the H is an s and the F
is going to have the
one last electron
missing in the p orbital.
S plus p must give
sigma always.
Because that's this cartoon.
See there's no way that when
this smears with this, there's
going to be zero electron
holidays from the hydrogen
nucleus to the fluorine
nucleus.
So you're going to end
up with something
that looks like this.
It starts around and gives you
something that's going to be a
little bit asymmetric.
So this will also be a sigma.
So I'll just put HF here as sort
of prototypical of that.
And then if I take p plus p
axially, on axis, that also
gives us a sigma.
Because that's this one,
the infinity signs.
Two infinity signs
give us this.
And then finally, if we get
p plus p longitudinally.
So that will give us a pi
bond and that's the 88.
8 plus 8 gives me,
and this is pi.
So that's quantum mechanics.
The math will follow.
So now what I want to do is go
back to this energy level
diagram and show how
these energy level
diagrams can work.
So here's the energy level
diagram for nitrogen, N2.
There's two f's, two p, and the
scaffolding is in place.
There's the energy levels.
Now here's the molecular
orbitals and here are the
atomic orbitals.
And now here they
are occupied.
So nitrogen has one, two, three,
four, five according to
the Hund rule.
And here is the set up
for the N2 molecules.
So the 2s's and the 2s's
go bonding antibonding.
Now I've got three plus
three is six.
Two, two, two.
Everything's paired.
So we get the triple bond,
946 kilojoules per mole.
Enormous energy in nitrogen.
Now, let's keep going.
Now let's look at oxygen.
This is the scaffolding for
oxygen and fluorine.
And there's a little
change here.
A little change, I'm going to
draw your attention to it.
And you can't predict this.
We would give you this.
I would tell you what the energy
sequence is of the
energy levels.
But look here carefully, you see
in the case all nitrogen,
the pi's lie below the sigma.
In the case of oxygen and
fluorine the sigma
lies below the pi's.
These are tiny, tiny
differences.
But, they are measurable.
That's the little difference.
Now let's see what happens.
Actually here's from out text
book and it shows the stigma
2pix slowly meandering down,
down, down, down, down.
And somewhere between nitrogen
and oxygen it crisscrosses.
All right, so now let's
fill oxygen.
So oxygen is two,
four, five, six.
So two plus two is four.
There's the two, two, two.
And then these last ones go
up into the antibonding.
But look at the antibonding.
We have, according to the Hund
rule, not two electrons in the
first orbital, but
one and one.
So we end up with unpaired
electrons in
the antibonding orbital.
So these offset the three pairs
here, and so we end up
with a double bond.
And its energy us 498
kilojoules per mole.
Substantially less
then nitrogen.
And this energy level diagram
rationalizes that.
And then here's for fluorine.
If you go to fluorine it's the
same scaffolding only there's
two more electrons.
These are paired and you
have a single bond.
160 kilojoules per mole.
Now there's a property that we
get from the fact that we have
these unpaired electrons.
We're going back oxygen now.
We have unpaired electrons in
the antibonding orbitals.
We saw unpaired electrons.
What did they do in the
Stern-Gerlach experiment?
Changed the magnetics
substantially, right?
We ended up with the splitting
of the silver bean.
So this will also
have an impact.
An impact known as
a paramagnetism.
What's paramagnetism?
It's shown in this
little cartoon.
If you have a substance here
that's balanced and it is
paramagnetic, if you engage
the magnetic field, the
magnetic field will pull on a
substance that's paramagnetic.
And oxygen is paramagnetic.
Not only in a gas state, but
paramagnetic as liquid.
And here's an illustration
from your text book.
You may have seen this and said,
yeah a guy is pouring
liquid oxygen, wow.
Look carefully now.
The boiling point of oxygen
at one atmosphere
pressure is 90 Kelvin.
So room temperature is
substantially higher.
This is the equivalent of taking
water and putting it in
an oven at about 300 degrees
celsius and watching it pour.
It would still be liquid,
but it would be
liquid trying to boil.
Why doesn't it all
turned to gas?
Because there's a time
to heat everything.
So this is sitting at 90 Kelvin,
he pouring it down, or
she's pouring it down, and
these are the jaw of a
permanent magnet.
And it's in a gravity
field, it doesn't
keep falling, it stops.
And it continues to boil away
and as fast as you can pour
it, it sits between the
jaws of the magnet.
Because it's paramagnetic.
You can think of this
as the liquid
equivalent of iron filings.
If I told you that were these
were iron filings you'd say,
yeah the iron filings go and
they stick to the magnet,
that's what magnets do
to iron filings.
They do the same thing
to liquid oxygen.
And why?
Because of this.
This explains this.
So we can do a lot with these
primitive little diagrams.
Let's do one more.
I want to do one more
of these things.
I want to go to hybridized
systems. I want to go to a
hybridized system.
And I want to look
at ethylene.
C2H4 is ethylene.
OK, so if I told you give me
the Louis structure of
ethylene, you just start going
according to the rule.
So I'm going to have carbon,
carbon, hydrogen, hydrogen.
And carbon has one, two,
three, four electrons.
The hydrogen has one electron.
I'll put the one electron
from hydrogen.
And then the other carbon
over here, I'm
going to give it dots.
One, two, three, four.
And then these hydrogen
each have one.
And now let's see what
I have here.
These hydrogens are all
isoelectronic with helium, so
they're happy.
And the carbon now has two,
let's see, what does he got?
Yeah, carbon is happy.
Two, four, six, OK good.
So now carbon is.
Happy as well.
So what do we have here?
This is the equivalent to a
carbon carbon double bond.
So what have I learned with
the nitrogen example?
What I learned with the nitrogen
example was, that if
I want to make more than one
bond, I have to have a
combination of a stigma
and a pi.
You can only make one sigma bond
because there's no room.
Once you've got zero electron
density between the two nuclei
you're going to violate the
Pauli exclusion principle if
you have another
orbital cutting
through that same domain.
So this means that multiple
bonds require a mix
of sigma and pi.
Multiple bonds require a
mix of sigma and pi.
If you have a single bond, all
you need is the sigma.
So let's go back to how we got
the original hybridization.
Remember, we started with
carbon, with the box notation
looking like this.
Here's the 2s and the 2p's and
we started with just native
carbon off the periodic table.
And we have this.
Just if we go according
to the 2s2, 2p2.
And then in order to get
hybridization to rationalize
methane, where we've got
four equivalent bonds.
In that case, we hybridize
the s and all of the p's.
We took the s and all three
of the p's to make
the sp3 hybrid orbitals.
And then we were able to take
these electrons and put them
in one at a time.
And then bring in the four
hydrogens and we end up with
something that is
symmetrically disposed in space.
The carbon, hydrogen and so.
So now I give to you ethylene
I say, well
how do I make ethylene.
Well, if I started with this sp3
thing maybe I could bring
another carbon over here.
And I'd have three hydrogen
sticking out.
So there's my sigma bond.
So I'm off to the races.
This is good.
But now I need to build
a second bond.
I'm going to throw away
a couple of hydrogen.
So i'll throw this hydrogen away
and this hydrogen away.
So I'm going to have now C2H4.
I'm almost there.
The only problem is, this
orbital is sticking out this
way, this orbital is sticking
out this way.
And I don't have the license
to bend these orbitals.
And build a double bond.
Because they're 109 degrees
apart and they're inflexible
and they won't bend.
So this hybridization technique
will not work as
such to give me what I need
to build ethylene.
What do I need?
If I'm going to build a sigma
and a pi bond, I'm going to
need to preserve one of the p
orbitals so that it can still
be available for lateral
smearing
Because how do I make
a pi orbital?
I make a pi orbital
middle with an 88.
So I need to preserve a p
orbital so that in both of the
carbons I still have this
pi bonding capability.
So what I'm going do is instead
of taking the s and
all three of the p's I'm going
to take the s and only two of
the p' s and reserve one of the
p' s to be sitting there
for lateral smearing.
So instead what I'm going
to do is this.
So this is going to be an
unmixed p and this is going to
take the s and not three
p' s but only two p 's.
And this would be called sp2.
And now what do I have?
I've one, two, three.
And how do I put three
of these in space?
They lie symmetrically in
a plane at 120 degrees.
And then this thing is normal
to the plane of the board.
It's sticking out.
Actually, I should've
maybe drawn it in
perspective like this.
And so now I've got
the ability to put
two of these together.
This'll giving me my sigma.
And then these two things lying
on their side will smear
with the lobes to
give me the pi.
Now that's what gives
me the double bond.
And here are the cartoons
that show this.
Oh here, I took this from an old
text book, it's text book
I had when I was your age.
The wrote great books.
And then I flipped
this around see.
I did all this just for you.
So I took this one, I flipped
the image around.
So there are the sp2's these
are the unmixed p's.
And you bring them close
together and bingo.
There's the sigma.
That's this one, p plus p
axially, that gives me the
sigma bond.
And then I smear those two
and that gives me the pi.
And there's ethylene.
You put the hydrogens here,
one, two, three, four.
Two carbons.
Tada.
Isn't that cool?
Here's from another book.
It's looks like a Boston traffic
map, doesn't it?
Just crazy.
This is from our book.
So they're showing you there's
the sigmas and the pi's.
There we go.
More pictures.
OK, I'm going to take three
minutes at the end here and
show you an example of
electronegativity at the extreme.
So if you take a look at the
periodic table and look at a
compound like sodium iodide.
If I just told you sodium
iodide, covalent or ionic?
You'd say, ionic.
Because you got something from
the the most metallic of the
metals and something
from the most non
metallic of the non metals.
And you're right.
And the delta chi is 1.73.
And the covalent character
is high.
And you end up with something
that's very polar and so on.
Now here's a very interesting
one, if you compare cesium and
gold, you get 1.75.
Which is greater than what it
was for sodium and iodine.
Now no one would argue that
sodium and iodine is covalent,
you'd argue that's ionic.
Well by the same metrics, cesium
and gold is as ionic.
The plot thickens.
Cesium, if you melt it it's
a metal, liquid metal.
If you melt gold, it's
a liquid metal.
But if you mix them
in equal number.
So you make a alloy of 50 mole
percent cesium and 50 mole
percent gold and you've got
a delta chi 1.75, you've
essentially made a cocktail with
equal numbers of really
good electron donors and really
good electron acceptors.
And guess what happens,
electron transfer.
And the melt is not metallic,
it turns clear and colorless
just as molten sodium
iodide would be.
It turns into a molten salt.
So cesium gives its
electron to gold.
And gold becomes the
negative gold ion.
And what color is every ion?
It's got stable octet
configurations.
It's got be the same color as
neon, argon, and helium.
They are clear and colorless.
Big drop in electrical
conductivity and a shift from
electronic to ionic
conduction.
Metals have electronic
conductivity, ions, what do
ionic liquids have?
They have like ionic
conductivity.
Here's some data from
the literature.
This is the log on the
connductivity as a function of
concentration.
So here's pure cesium
over here, here's
pure gold over here.
This is 600 degrees C.
So the line stops here because
gold melts at about 1060.
So gold is a solid beyond this
alloy concentration.
But you can see this is roughly
what you'd get.
So electronic conductivity up
here at about 10 to the 4
siemens per, this is reciprocal
ohms, but siemens
per centimeter.
And down here, this is very low
value ionic conductivity.
So this is a liquid metal.
And this is a molten solid.
And it all happens just
when you get very
very close to 50/50.
So you end up with something
called cesium oride.
And it's sorcery.
You have one vial
of liquid metal.
You have a second vial
You pour then and it turns
clear and colorless.
And the conductivity drops three
orders of magnitude all
because of electron transfer due
to this electronegativity
difference.
That's so cool.
That is so cool.
OK, with that I'll let you go.
We'll see you on Friday.